CHUO-LING CHANG: Welcome.
Today we're going to talk
about streaming your game
to reach new users.
This is an exciting
project at Google
that helps game
developers reach many more
users beyond your install base.
And in the next 45 minutes, I'll
show you what we have built,
I'll explain to you-- or we'll
explain to you-- how it works,
and also tell you
as a game developer
how you can participate.
And in the end, we also
have time for questions.
So let's start.
PETER TAN: So hi, I'm Peter.
As a game developer you have put
tons of effort into your game,
and finally it's
available on Google Play.
Now it's time to
let the world know.
There are many ways
and opportunities
to get users to play your games.
And Google has been [INAUDIBLE]
in helping developers
to achieve that.
For example, many
people go to Google Play
where they can browse
categories, top charts,
trendings to find
a game they love.
Users can also search for
specific games, or a category
like car racing, where
a grid of relevant games
will show up on top
of the search results.
And in Apps, Google
offers various formats
such as banner ads,
interstitials, and videos
to showcase your games.
So for all these various moments
when users are on mobile,
we try to grab users'
attention, give them
enough information
about your games,
and then convince them to
click this green button which
I'm sure you are all
very familiar with.
Now is a decision time for users
to click, to install or not
to install.
Personally I'd like to
play, to try many games.
And since most of
the games are free,
I can just install games,
play the game for a while.
If I don't like it, I can
uninstall and then move on
to the next one.
However, this install, try,
uninstall process is kind
of tedious and time consuming.
Even users are just one tap away
from trying your awesome games,
they might not have time
to wait for the download.
They may not want to
let the games eat up
their phone storage.
For whatever reasons, metrics
generally show less than 10%
of users who visit the
game page are going
to click this Install button.
And as you can imagine, if the
button comes with a price tag,
it's not even possible for
users to try your games.
So we have been
thinking, what else
can we do to make users
understand your game better
before installation?
What else can we
do to make users
feel this is a game they'd
really like before downloading?
What if we show
users this Try Now
button which makes
the process of trying
the game as fast and as easy
as watching a video on YouTube.
Our solution is App Streaming.
CHUO-LING CHANG: So
what is App Streaming?
To enable this "try
now" experience,
instead of asking our user
to first wait for a download,
we actually pre-install the
app in a virtual Android
device running in the cloud.
So as soon as the user
clicks on the Try Now button,
we start again in the cloud,
and the audio and visual content
generated by the
game is then captured
and streamed all the way
down to the user's device.
This is similar to how
videos are streamed
on services like YouTube.
And in addition, to let the
user interact with the game,
we also capture user
controls such as the touch
gestures, and then stream
them back up to the cloud,
so that the game can update
its content accordingly.
This two-way
exchange is carefully
designed to run fast
and smooth, such
that the user can enjoy the game
as if it was installed locally
on the device.
Now, let me give you a
more concrete example.
Today in the Google
App on Android,
let's say our user Jen
searches for Candy Crush
by typing it into
the Google search
box on the top of your
Android home screen.
In the Search Result
page, in addition to
the Install button
you are familiar with,
there is now also
a "try now" option.
As soon as Jen clicks
on the Try Now button,
she's immediately
launched into the game.
And at this point, the
screen is already generated
and streamed down
from the cloud.
And Jen can start
playing right away.
And some of you might have
noticed that in the App Stream
experience, there's this
additional G button that
actually floats
on top of the game
and can be moved
around in case it
covers some important
elements in the game.
At any moment during
the game play,
Jen can click on this G button
which gives her more options.
For example, Jen can
choose to install
the game from Google Play.
Or she can go back to the
previous Search Result page.
Or she can simply get back to
the game and continue playing.
We currently limit the length
of this trial experience
in Search to up to 10 minutes.
And at the end up
this 10-minute trial,
Jen will be presented again with
an option to install the game.
By now, she should be
very familiar with what
this game is about.
And if she likes the game,
if she wants to play it more,
she can then install the
game on her phone from here.
This feature is already live
in the Google App on Android.
And we are already
streaming hundreds
of games including popular
titles like Candy Crush, Angry
Birds, and Cut the Rope.
So if you have an Android
phone, please give it a
try after the session.
PETER TAN: So in
addition to Search,
we also integrate App
Streaming into a new app
format called Trial Run Apps.
Let's look at how
the product works.
Our user Jen is playing a
game called Bears versus Art.
When she finishes one level
and goes to the next level,
her ads pop up.
And she notices that this is
a ad about game called 1010!
Puzzle.
It looks like it
has a good rating.
And she can try the game by
clicking the Try Now button.
So she does.
The 1010!
Puzzle will be
launched instantly.
And she can play the game,
get a pretty good feeling
about what the game is about.
And when the trial is
over, she has the option
to install the game.
Next slide.
So if she likes the game, she
can install in Google Play.
We launched these trial run
ads in beta six months ago.
And in our early
tests, an advertiser
has seen a 20% increase
in conversion rate.
In addition, since users
are getting a test of games
before going through
the download process,
we think the
developer can attract
users who are more
engaged because users
have chosen a game based on
their experience in a trial.
CHUO-LING CHANG: Now it's
time to show some live demos.
So let's do this.
So can everyone see the screen?
So what I'm going to demo is
App Streaming in Google Search.
So let's say I heard
about this Angry Birds
game called Angry Birds Rio.
So I look it up by typing it
into the Google Search box.
There's now this
"try now" option.
So I click on Try Now.
I'm already in the game.
And you can see that
there's a bar [? glow ?]
saying App Streaming
powered by Google.
[MUSIC FROM THE GAME]
And at this point, you
hear the audio, too.
The user can already
interact with the game.
I can just go directly into
stage one and start playing.
You can see that I
can already move =.
And also multi-touch works.
Let me try to do this.
[BIRDS CAWING AND CRATES
BREAKING]
So let me try one more level.
I think you get the idea.
So I like this game very much,
I want to have it on my phone.
What do I do?
I click on this button, and
then I can just-- oh, sorry.
I click on this button.
I can just install
the game right here.
And this is how it works,
how App Streaming works
inside Google Search.
PETER TAN: Let's also look at
how the App Streaming works
for trial run ads.
So what you are seeing
here is an interstitial ad
for a game Two Dots.
And just like all
the interstitial ads,
it has a pretty creative.
It has a name and a rating.
But now, I also have a Try
Now button here I can tap.
And instead of watching
a video ad passively,
I'm now dropped
right into a game
and I can fully
interact with the game.
And it looks like the
first part of the game,
just like a lot of
games, is a tutorial.
Which is great,
because now I don't
need to read a description
from the Google Play.
I can just follow the
tutorial like this
and then learn how
to play, and then
decide if I like
the game or not.
And actually, I already played
this tutorial like 100 times,
so I got pretty good at it.
And you may notice
that for ads, there's
also a timer on top
of the screen which
reminds users how much time
you have for the trial.
Time's up.
And then the user will
have the opportunity
to tap Install and
go to the Play Store,
and then download the game.
So this is our demo.
CHUO-LING CHANG: So
now let's come back
to talk more about how
App Streaming works.
First we run an army of
Android virtual machines
on Google Cloud Platform,
which is Google's public cloud
offering that is rapidly
expanding around the globe.
So you can think of these
Android virtual machines
as running the actual
Android operating
system on virtualized
CPUs in the cloud.
And just like the Linux
VMs and Windows VMs
you usually see on
Google Cloud Platform
or any other
[? elastic ?] clouds,
these Android VMs can be
quickly spinned up or torn down
on demand.
And that is how we
scale App Streaming
to serve Google users.
The Android VMs currently
run Android Marshmallow.
And we regularly
apply system patches
to make sure that
these games always
run in up-to-date environments
for best performance.
Now as you can
imagine, in the cloud
these Android VMs do not
have physical touch panels
or physical displays
attached to them.
In order to support
device input, what we do
is we customize these
Androids in the [INAUDIBLE]
abstraction layer so that they
can take virtual input events
streamed from the
user's physical device
all the way across the internet.
And similarly, to
support device output,
in the VM we capture the
rendering, frame buffer,
and audio samples and code
them into video bit stream,
and send it down to the user.
To deliver a fully
interactive experience,
this additional two-way latency
introduced by App Streaming
needs to be as low as possible.
So we actually spent a lot
of efforts streamlining
every single component
in this system,
all the way from
the mobile client,
the network, and also
the cloud servers.
In our current implementation,
the processing time
and buffering time on the client
and on the server combined
is only 60 milliseconds.
And in the US, the
network roundtrip time
from the user to a Google
Call Phone Data Center
is typically around
20 to 40 milliseconds.
That means in total, App
Streaming only adds up to 60
plus 40-- 100
milliseconds of latency.
That's 1/10 of a second.
And as you all saw
earlier in the demos,
this number is low enough
such that we can still
deliver an enjoyable
mobile gaming experience.
As you all know, in
streaming applications
network conditions can
have a very big impact
on the quality of service.
And network conditions can vary.
It not only varies from
connection to connection, even
within a single connection
the network condition
can vary significantly
over time.
To cope with network condition
variations, what we do
is we adapt the video
quality in real time,
to the live network conditions.
For example, we adapt
the video bit rate
from around one megabits
per second all the way
to more than five
megabits per second.
And similarly, we also
adapt the video frame rate
from around 15 frames per
second to the regular 60 frames
per second.
We also adapt a level of
protection against packet loss,
based on how lossy the
network is in real time.
And with all of these
adaptation efforts,
we're able to run App
Streaming smoothly
on a variety of Wi-Fi
and 4G cellular networks.
PETER TAN: I hope by now you
feel excited about this novel
approach to reach new users.
So how do you get started?
Very simple.
Please go to
g.co/appstreaminggames
and answer a few simple
questions on the phone
and [INAUDIBLE].
And that's it.
The rest of the work is on us.
We will use the same APK
you publish on Google Play
and create an App
Streaming experience.
And while technically you do
not need to modify the APK,
please keep in mind that
this is a time-limited trial.
Meaning that offering an
intuitive, fun experience
in the first few
minutes is going
to be an important thing for
users and keep users engaged.
We think this is a good design
in general for all the games,
so hopefully your game
already does this.
And for trial run ads, if
you have a complicated game
or something that's very
difficult to showcase
in a limited time,
you have the option
to provide us a custom APK.
For example, you can start
a game from level 36,
or you can start a game with a
character with very fancy gear.
So there's option there
for the trial run ads.
CHUO-LING CHANG: So
finally, some key takeaways.
As a game developer, you can
now reach many more users
beyond your install
base with the "try now"
functionality powered
by Google App Streaming.
Users no longer need
to wait for a download
before they can
experience your game.
And this removes
a lot of friction
in getting high-value users
with better engagement.
We're already streaming
hundreds of games
in Google Search and Ads.
So to also get
your game streamed,
please sign up at
g.co/appstreaminggames.
And you can even get it done
without a single line of code
change.
And with that, we thank
you for your attention.
But again, please go sign up,
and then also give it a try
on your phone.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
CHUO-LING CHANG: So next we'll
open the floor to questions.
And our Product
Manager [INAUDIBLE]
will join us on stage.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you
guys go to the center,
please, where the microphone
is and line up for Q&A, please?
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
What about native
games and 3D games?
And can you launch into a
specific point in a game?
CHUO-LING CHANG: So let me
first answer the first one.
Native and 3D games, I mean,
the games you actually saw
were native and 3D or--
OK, the short answer
is we do support
native and 3D games.
And currently we support
all graphics [INAUDIBLE].
We run graphics
[INAUDIBLE] in the cloud.
So 3D games work.
That's the answer.
And the second question?
AUDIENCE: The full
OpenGL support.
What about Vulcan support?
CHUO-LING CHANG: OpenGL, yes.
Not Vulcan yet.
Because we also run
Android Marshmallow,
so Vulcan is not there yet.
AUDIENCE: And then launching
to a specific point,
say, an interesting
part of the [INAUDIBLE]?
PETER TAN: Yeah, so right now,
to launch to a specific point
will require you
provide us a custom APK.
We don't have a way
to take a stock APK
and then launch to
a specific point.
AUDIENCE: There's not
like a custom [INAUDIBLE].
PETER TAN: However, technically,
if you can provide us, say,
a deep link, then
we can possibly
use a deep link to jump into
a specific game you like.
AUDIENCE: That's good.
OK.
Thank you.
CHUO-LING CHANG:
So deep links work.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
What kind of metrics
do you provide?
Like how long
people do the trial?
What conversion?
Do you guys expose
any of that data
so we can see how
well it's performing?
CHUO-LING CHANG: We don't yet,
but we do have the numbers.
And we are looking into how
we can share these numbers
with our partners.
And that's also
one of the reasons
we are asking all of you to
sign up and give us feedback,
so we can figure
out together what
numbers you are looking for.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have two questions.
The first is, can I try
the game, like "try now"
multiple times?
PETER TAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes?
And every trial has
the same time limit?
CHUO-LING CHANG:
So right now this
is a number we currently set.
So in Search, like the use case
I demo-ed inside the Google
App, the limit is set to 10
minutes per session per trial.
And for apps--
PETER TAN: So for apps, I think
developer can choose the time.
It really depends on the game.
Some games, user can get a
full picture within 30 seconds.
But some game might be 90
seconds or 120 seconds.
I think there's an option there.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Brilliant [INAUDIBLE].
Really, really, really good.
PETER TAN: Oh, thank you,
AUDIENCE: Any
technical restrictions
on things like Play Services,
logins, or fair play plugins,
or that kind of stuff?
First thing our
games generally do
is we'll do sign-ins,
connect to Facebook,
download loads of stuff.
How does the game start up?
FEMALE SPEAKER: So right
now when users stream,
it's done anonymously, where
if they would like to sign in,
they can still enter their
username and sign in like that.
We're looking into
doing integration
where, at least for Google
Play Games integration,
the user gets
automatically signed
in when they start streaming.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm doing virtual reality games.
And I wonder if my
game will be downloaded
and the user later decides to
install it, in emerging markets
will this require to re-download
again all the activity code
and all assets again
on mobile internet?
How about saving bandwidth?
CHUO-LING CHANG: Currently, what
we stream down are all pixels.
So we don't stream any assets.
So if the user do want
to install the app,
he needs to do the
whole downloading again.
But there is some possibility
that we can integrate these two
directly together.
Like while streaming we
can do partial downloading.
But this is something we can
look into, but we haven't.
AUDIENCE: The question is these
games only work with the games
that have expansion files?
So actually when you're running
it on the virtual machine,
you're running what you have
already on the console there?
Or it can also work
for the kind of games
that we are using with our
CDM to download the content?
PETER TAN: Do you
mean the OBD file?
The extension file?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
When you're running it on
the virtual machine, what
you are running is
the APK plus the OBD.
PETER TAN: Yes, we
also run with OBD.
AUDIENCE: What happens
with the kind of games,
in example, in
the company I work
for, we have some APKs
that when you download it,
then we go through
a-- an installer
thinks that we
are not using OBD.
We are downloading the data
from the CDM that we have.
PETER TAN: So I think right
now those kind of games,
meaning that after
the first launch
they might want to download
additional file or something.
And some type of games that
would take maybe a minute
or even more to download.
Those kind of games currently
doesn't work with us.
But we are also looking
to that possible solution.
For example, pre-fetch or
pre-download [INAUDIBLE]
before take a snapshot
and serving to user.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I have three questions.
What's the minimum
bandwidth for streaming?
CHUO-LING CHANG: So
the current system
is set to 1 to 1.5
megabits per second.
And the fast one is over five.
So there's this range.
AUDIENCE: And how
about the maximum users
can try their streaming
at the same time?
Because there are lots of
users around the world.
And [INAUDIBLE].
PETER TAN: Yeah.
So in terms of computing power,
there's always a limit, right?
But because we are
running on the Google Data
Center and Google
Cloud Platform,
so our theoretical
limit will be the limit
of whatever the Google Cloud
Platform can provide to us.
AUDIENCE: And the final
question is, is the user trial
run currently online?
PETER TAN: Yes, it's live.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
PETER TAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just a question around the
degradation of the networks.
So like with video there's
dynamic adaptive streaming.
Do you guys do something
similar to make sure
that the experience
is consistent?
So if my network
quality gets worse,
does the streaming
quality get worse?
CHUO-LING CHANG: Yes,
we do something similar.
So if you do have a low
bandwidth, the video you see,
the stream app you see will
be slightly more pixilated.
The firmware might
be slightly lower,
but we make sure the
experience is still
smooth enough so the user
still can enjoy the game.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Good job.
Two questions.
One is, does the app
know it's being streamed?
And the second question is, does
this work with app indexing?
CHUO-LING CHANG: I guess
I'll take the first part.
So the app, when we start the
activity with normal Android
intent, and currently we
do provide a special intent
to tell the app you are in
the App Streaming experience.
So if developer really want
to know for referral purpose,
for tracking purpose,
there's a way for them
to know this is a game
or this is a traffic
coming from the App Streaming.
AUDIENCE: So we could use that
to customize the experience
and try it out.
CHUO-LING CHANG:
Yes, that's possible.
AUDIENCE: A related question
is on that app indexing,
because if the search
results can take you
straight into a special
section of the app,
does that work right now?
PETER TAN: It does.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes.
PETER TAN: I think if your app
or games support app indexing,
I think it would also work
on our streaming experience.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
PETER TAN: I think we are good.
CHUO-LING CHANG: So if
there's no more questions,
I mean, we'll still be
here, hang out with you.
And please come to us if
you have more questions,
or you want to have
more discussions.
PETER TAN: And we
also have a phone,
so if you want to just
try it personally,
we can show you the phone.
And we'll also be available
in the Search Sandbox.
So find us over in the
Search Sandbox outside.
Thank you.
CHUO-LING CHANG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]